all right randina and Alex
where are you guys from originally
where'd you grow up so I was born in
Nebraska Omaha Nebraska and I grew up in
mainly in like little Barn Hawaiian
Gardens California area
um after we moved because my mom she got
divorced from my dad after she found out
he was cheating on her we got deported
in Mexico I was like five years old she
wasn't paying the bills or anything she
was just going out partying and not
really taking care of me and my brother
I mean my brother was trying to give me
any of his food from lunch that he would
save from school so there's that I was
like really skinny when I was little and
then at night I was trying to get you
into a new gang no I'm not not yet not
no it was until I moved to Hawaiian
Gardens like when a lot of my like
people who I looked up to were getting
related and like they were trying you
know to get me Affiliated but I didn't
really join that I kind of avoided that
type of nonsense because one of my
greatest influences like I called my
Uncle Matthew husky he um dropped out of
the gang because I influenced him to not
be a part of the gang anymore because I
wasn't about that life and
he moved to Colorado so I felt like I
did a big impact right there you know
and
I tried my best to be a good person and
I was born in Anaheim but grew up like
in Hawaiian Gardens and Lakewood or by
the Long Beach town center kind of Long
Beach Lakewood Cerritos border of all
those cities
um my parents put me in good schools
they put me in Los Alamitos from middle
school up to high school I even won prom
queen but
um
we found out my little brother had
cancer when I was about 13.
and you know I my dad has always been
like heavily Gang Related and I grew up
around that kind of thing in my whole
life
and my parents were doing drugs you know
when they found out my brother had
cancer they
graduated from pills to heroin I
remember finding their needles in the
trash can one day when I I knew they
were doing it but when I found out that
they were doing it like that
I I knew things were you know going down
that rough path and
after that I kind of had to watch over
my brothers more like as if they were my
kids
and I grew up helping you know raise my
brother's cook for them clean for them I
was pretty much like always doing things
for them helping them in school helping
them graduate you know my brother with
cancer unfortunately after covet he
didn't even get to graduate high school
but you know after high school was when
I met Alex
he was uh working for one of my dad's
friends that started coming over to the
house he was Gang Related and that's how
we met
yeah like um one of the friend that
she's talking about his name is Amador
they call him Pedro he he uh he's Gang
Related and like you know he he got me
working again and stuff like that so he
he was like somebody who I looked up to
who like I felt was like a good
influential gang-related person and um
me personally my my the definition of
gangster that I've learned is to look
after your neighborhood you know look
after your people not what gangster
means nowadays you know so like I look
up to like old school gangsters so um
like they're very cool who got me
working again he told me that you know
in order to live life you need to have
like a steady job and things like that
because I used to manufacture medical
students for brain aneurysms but I lost
that job when I went to jail and I
stopped working and I started slacking
off and after I met
um her dad her dad was like kind of like
my like heroin dealer you know she
didn't like because my heroin dealers
initially Puerto Rico and went to her
dad and then um because he would pick up
from his her dad so right met the top
head I guess and then I met her and I
was like really in love as soon as I met
her as soon as I got like like knocked
on the door and asked for her dad and
she answered and I was just really happy
to meet her you know and and then after
that her dad seemed to like me a lot and
wanted me around a lot more often
helping her out and and I would and I
was bringing money to the table it was
until after her mom killed herself
that's when things started shaking up
and her dad like stopped liking me
because I guess he was seeing the
reflection of his relationship right in
front of him he um pistol whips me
because he started believing rumors from
others who were jealous of me for being
with her I guess everybody wanted to be
with her yeah there were a lot of people
that were jealous and being someone's
daughter especially like as heavy as my
dad is like in the area where he does
his thing or whatever you know he's got
everybody telling him all kinds of stuff
but mainly a lot of people a lot of guys
that were just jealous or mad I don't
know I don't know what it was but you
know I didn't do anything didn't talk to
any of them you know I think it was just
because they wanted to get
some points with my dad or something by
telling him this or saying that because
like I was a good girl I was in Girl
Scouts for like
12 13 years I didn't do anything but go
to school and come home my parents
wouldn't let me go anywhere they want to
let me hang out with friends I barely
got to go to school events but when I
did get to go to those school events I
did have fun and I made enough friends
and enough connections to wear and you
know my senior year they voted me prom
queen you know everything was good up
until
about after I graduated high school
things started getting really bad my
grandpa started dying he had diabetes
and lung cancer and I was taking care of
him for a handful full years until he
died
and then after he died he left the house
to my dad
but then my mom and dad ended up in jail
because they got caught
um
I guess they got caught with with like
some pounds in the car they went down to
Mexico to buy a car from somebody and
got set up and ended up in jail both of
them for a year
and I had to take care of the house and
the bills and my brothers and I wasn't
getting any help and I had to do it all
by myself and when they came back
everybody said that I wasn't doing
anything and I hadn't helped and if it
weren't for me they wouldn't even have
had the house still and it was all just
for them to get out and they ended up
fighting my mom ended up killing herself
and now my dad's just running
rampant he's running a muck and
uh
I don't know how it's going over there I
haven't talked to my brothers or any of
my family in about like like almost two
years now upgraded to fentanyl her dad
upgraded to fentanyl now so I'm pretty
sure he's shooting it
um and it's funny because like a lot of
the people from the hood they like kind
of fear my mom because like my mom she
put a lot of work in the hood she's not
Gang Related same with my dad they both
our parents are are heavily known in the
hood like and my mom she used to like be
a pimp and like she she was she's pretty
well known and like people know know me
because of my mom and and due to that
like I I don't understand why like such
a switch up because everybody loved me
and now everybody hates me and it's it's
so weird because seeing that happen it's
just stupid because why can't people
just be so like friendly and like nice
to people you know like why can't peace
just exist like why why do people just
have to act like such such jealousy and
envy for for no reason like people who
can't just be themselves I'm like me I'm
myself every day you know and that's why
she loves me you know and maybe if
people started acting like themselves
like maybe they could have probably at
least achieved something other than
nothing you know and have to keep on
envying everybody that they see around
them
you know and um
you know for for most of my high school
years you know I started like I was in
honors you know I was all throughout
High School I was in honors but my only
problem was drugs I started smoking weed
at like 12 after my Grandpa died and I
was living in San Bernardino I was
paying my mom's rent for for a cool
minute you know like I was I was selling
her narcos and so much because she
wasn't taking them she was addicted to
meth and then after that like
um after my Grandpa died I started
smoking the weed and then started
popping pills and then after that 13 I
started popping more pills but then I
quit because you know pills aren't
really the thing to do then I upgraded
to meth after you know a little my first
heartbreak you know and um I walked into
the bathroom I was going to guard high
school and um because I got kicked out
of Artesia High School and at guard I
walked into the bathroom and I seen one
person from Chivas which is like enemies
of Hawaiian Gardens they were sniffing
the line of of mess and um they asked me
if I wanted some because they thought I
was going to snitch him out and you know
they just wanted to see if I'll do it
and I accidentally sniffed the whole
like whole because it was like a piece
of paper fold it in half 200 worth of
meth right there and it sniffed the
whole thing on accident
around the mile and I felt fine you know
like I told the person was I told the
person I was just like I'm sorry I'll
pay you back he's just like paying me
back by living you know and um after
that uh I just got heavily addicted
after I because I could quit for a year
of meth and then I felt like I went back
to it after I started smoking and
smoking it is like the most heavily
addicting way to do it you know my mom
she said like she didn't want me smoking
it because of the fact that once you
start hitting that pipe you're not gonna
put it down and is that it's true like I
never did put it up after that and then
after that I upgraded to heroin after
like I started getting a little bit more
depressed after I found out my mom had
leukemia I started heroin at like 18.
and then after that um
like somehow I mean I kind of met her
and then I quit you know him for like 10
days but then she said that she doesn't
she doesn't mind that if I do it or not
you know and um I was already addicted
so like
how was how was I going to keep doing it
and be with him and him not be doing it
yeah because like the way that her dad
would pay me was like like letting me
live there and like I told her dad that
like I would quit you know for his
daughter and I did I quit for 10 days
but like she would not have me ask him
for my payment to be like you know the
heroine and so I would ask him for
heroin even though that like I'm not
doing it he was questioning like why am
I asking him for heroin if I'm not doing
it
and um then like he kind of knew why he
knew that like I was still giving it to
her and like you know then I started
smoking it again and
um you didn't really like that uh after
that we kind of upgraded a fentanyl
after her dad kicked us out because um
in the streets it's hot it's easy it was
easier to find it was cheaper and I have
really bad teeth so yeah I kind of
started the same way like he did just
way later like he started at 13 messing
around with drugs I started like way
after high school probably like 19 like
early 20s and it started with my bad
teeth going to the dentist and then
they'd give me you know some antibiotics
and some Percocets and then they'd have
me come back in a week for the next
round and after that I just kept doing
pills here and there until then I
started
um messing around with the m30s the blue
uh fetty pills and after my parents
ended up in jail there was just a lot of
stress I couldn't handle it and and um
dope was easy money and there was a lot
of it around me so I did what I had to
do to make some money and keep paying
the house payment while also supplying
like enough for my habit too until I was
full-blown smoking it like every day
consistently and then you know once you
end up on the streets even just for a
little bit of time more than likely if
you're doing heroin you're probably
going to end up doing Freddie too if it
doesn't kill you so I ended up doing
Freddie because it was easier to find it
was way cheaper and and here we are you
know I tell my dad you don't want me
doing Freddie then help me not be on the
streets but instead he kicked me out on
the streets and
talk [__]
up on the same [__] that he's doing
he tried to keep me away from it my
whole life and I I stayed away from it
most my life but you know there's some
things that
that just can't be
can't be undone yeah you know like like
me homelessness started at like nine
when my mom moved back out here she had
a bad boyfriend he stabbed me three
times like right here in my chest
um because like he um he tried to show
me his heroin dealer and I started like
I was just playing Mortal Kombat and
like then there was heroin do the
criminals out and whips it whips his
dick out and then after I stabbed it and
then I thought like he hears his heroin
dealer screaming he comes out and then
if that he just stabs me three times and
I I'm surprised I didn't die how old
were you I was nine years old and I'm 23
now you know and um
all right not only that the other thing
I did was like one time me and my mom
and him we were in the car and it's
funny because I was like five years old
or six years old when I had a dream and
like um I don't know if you believe in
uh um I forgot what they're called there
are certain type of Dreams yeah
premonitions and like I had a
premonition right like six years old of
seeing a cat like waking up to inside of
the back of a car with a cat in front of
me my mom arguing with some guy with
like Devil horn tattoos and then later
on when I'm nine years old I see this
guy and like I'm realizing I'm reliving
that dream and um then I feel like I
realized what they were arguing about
they're arguing about me like being
hungry and after that like he hit my mom
and then after he hit my mom you know my
mom stopped her car and that he told me
to shut the [__] up after I said don't
help my mom and not that he like tried
to pull me out of the car pulled my arm
out of socket and then yeah just because
I was hungry so like you know people are
pretty [__] up you know and like I
learned that like like most men are just
shitty people you know and like I try my
best to not be a bad man you know and um
you know like throughout that time you
know I was on and off homeless moving in
with my aunt moving back out in the
streets with my mom and because I didn't
want to leave my mom alone you know I
had my best friend Christian he's like
more of a brother than my actual brother
you know like I would talk to him on the
phone and then after I started living
with my aunt for a little bit longer
from like being like 13 and up like to
like up to 18 you know like when I got
when I ran away from home at 17 my best
friend let me stay at his house for a
little bit until my aunt you know like
she she really wanted me home because
like I was stressing her out more after
I found out my aunt had cancer you know
this is my great aunt this is my mom's
Aunt you know so like she she's like a
she's like my mom to me like when it
comes to like you know coming down to
like the discipline and stuff like that
you know me being like a gentleman and
everything I learned that from my aunt
you know and my mom she's like living
with my aunt right now you know I I got
kicked out at 18 because you know always
have the addicted to imagine like you
know
um she might Aunt thought that I was
stealing from the house because I
wouldn't snitch on my mom for like her
stealing from the house and like that
caused me to get kicked out if I would
have opened my mouth and said I was my
mom my mom would have been in the
streets with the bad back and everything
and I would have been a shitty son for
doing that you know and um then I
started living with my best friend who's
like my brother and like he really
wanted me to quit meth but I couldn't
quit medicine
and then I ended up you know like
because like I didn't want to break his
break his heart anymore than I already
did because he's like my brother and
like you know I didn't want him to have
to feel like he has to push me away
sometimes because like he'll see me high
and like he did he wouldn't like me when
I'm high but you know sometimes you
sometimes he actually when I would keep
it quiet and not say anything about me
using
he wouldn't know that I'm using and he
would like prefer me like that but then
whenever I'm not using you know my
emotions show a lot more because like
I'm a very emotional person and and like
he didn't like that he doesn't he
doesn't like being around like emotional
people because she's like more of a shun
didn't person
but um that's still my best friend to
this day you know like if I was to go
there right now and like ask him for
help he would help me it's just you know
don't want to want him to see me are
anymore so until I get sober you know
where you guys staying now you're on the
streets
we're on the streets right now yeah kind
of anywhere we bounce back and forth
between here and Long Beach kind of
Hawaiian Gardens where our family is at
mostly hits because I don't really talk
to mine anymore
yeah and I'm well we try to stay away
from Hawaiian Gardens because her dad
has the whole Hood looking for me trying
to kill me I don't know about that I
think it's more just to scare you
because if
yeah I mean like
it's kind of like Puerto Rico he's he
like told me like her dad's like
basically trying to kill me so like I'm
very like paranoid to be out there my
dad just got a bad temper I don't know
like after I graduated in high school I
started taking care of my grandpa for
him because he just couldn't handle
seeing my grandpa like pretty much dying
like that
and um
you know after my Grandpa died was when
he kind of you know took a step off the
deep end so did I I started using drugs
a lot more started smoking a gang of
weed and doing pills a lot more
and um he started arguing with my mom a
lot more and then they went to jail
and I picked up heroin and things were
just things were really rough but and I
could barely afford to pay the bills and
the house payment it was it was a
struggle I had no one helping me and my
brothers are just looking down on me
because they knew I was getting high and
um my dad I told my dad and he kept it a
secret until there was a day where I
made the money late on his books and he
threatened me and he got on the phone
with my mom because I would pay to put
money on the phone for both of them to
put the phones together and as soon as
she got on the phone he told her that I
was doing heroin and um
actually surprisingly she was more
supportive and like just caring and
wanted me to quit like you know she was
more nice about it and I stopped for a
few but then my brother started treating
me real bad again and I was the one that
was doing everything for them buying the
food paying the bills and um
so I started doing it again and um then
they got out
and they kept fighting and my my mom and
my dad they kicked us out on the streets
for a couple weeks and then we came back
to the house
and my parents were still fighting like
more than ever and I noticed like they
hadn't been talking and my my dad
noticed that my mom hadn't been around
and he he asked me where my mom's at and
then he went in the backyard to go find
her and she had a little shed back there
where she hung out and did her own
little thing especially when they would
fight and he found her she had hung
herself and you know she she had a hard
life she grew up on the streets like
almost her whole life kind of like same
as him and her and her mom didn't have
the greatest relationship and I think
that kind of carried on with the way she
treated me
because we didn't really get along and
and I tried I tried to put effort there
and and it's just [__] up because you
know those two weeks before she did what
she did like I hadn't talked to her and
usually like when she's fighting with my
dad she'll come talk to me or say
something to me because there's like
Untold things that she said to me that
she hasn't shared with anybody including
him and like that just goes to shows
that goes to show that I think that she
did like really cherish the relationship
that she had with me she just couldn't
she didn't know how to do it how to deal
with having a daughter she was just
doing it the best way that she could you
know like based on how she grew up and
how she was treated
but it just makes me think like if maybe
if I was there and they hadn't kicked me
out she hadn't yelled at me and told me
to leave that night that maybe she would
have talked to me or I would have said
something to her and she'd still be
alive but
you know I don't know my dad he just
wants somebody to blame he yells at me
tells me that it's my fault that I
killed her you know and they were the
ones fighting but it was obviously just
a mental thing with her I think but you
know it's just messed up because people
say things and do things and and they
can't be undone but yeah you know I
think he carries a little bit of guilt I
think we all do everybody wants some
somebody to blame or something to blame
but
you know it's just the lifestyle really
in all actuality it seems like your dad
probably [__] killed it
no I think my mom was just tired she
seen no end to this life it's just it's
a life of of just stealing and trying to
make it to the to the next bill or the
next dollar or the next way you're gonna
get money for that next fix or the food
for the kids or whatever it may be but
well for yourself
partying and
[__] trying to be a part of the gang
more yeah I don't know I think he's like
maybe having a midlife crisis I think
especially after my mom did what she did
he's just trying to look for a way out
you know like it seems anyways upgrading
to the cartel
that's that's what it seems like it
seems like he's upgrading to the court
so okay my dad takes a lot of pride in
this gang life and he just wants to keep
leveling up but I think it's like one of
those things where he doesn't realize
what he's doing until it's already done
a little background on Hawaiian Gardens
like uh um the founding father of
Hawaiian Gardens is um the leader of the
Mexican Mafia so it's very cartel
related it's very like very deep in that
that that whole Mexican gang related
area you know then yeah it's a way it's
the reason why this such a small city is
so well known and well connected and
there's things like drugs and gangs and
all that and like
um in in like people from Hawaiian
Gardens are very well connected with
like cartel leaders and stuff like that
and so like her dad is like very well
connected with cartel stuff so like
that's why I just make that theory that
like you know he think he's like being a
part of the cartel now because like the
people he's been hanging around with and
yeah yeah and I don't know if he loves
it he loves the lifestyle he loves
being on top I don't know if it's just
a feeling of him feeling like he's
wanted or needed but he we're making aim
for himself
feel like the environment you guys grew
up in the families you grew up you grew
up in kind of
sealed your fate yeah definitely but a
little bit yeah I feel like there's like
no changing like there's nothing I could
have done to change what what was bound
to happen and me neither if I would have
done anything any other way I probably
would have ended up more [__] up
yeah if I would have never met her I
would have died from heroin overdose so
it definitely would have started smoking
because I know and like when I first did
fentanyl well like the second time I did
that and all because the first time I
did it I was 18 and I didn't like it I
hated it I honestly hated it and um I
never wanted to do it again because I
passed out and I got 300 stolen from me
so I did it again after like she really
wanted it would come down here to
downtown L.A where she's telling me that
like oh you could just go up there yeah
we were trying to get heroin but we
couldn't find it from anywhere and no
one would sell it to us we couldn't get
it anywhere and I knew down here uh
Betty was easy to get and it was cheap
you know he could walk up in a tent and
ask anybody for as much as you got or
trade anything that you got and after
that like I did it and then I went out
multiple times and um
she she if she was not there to nor
Academy I would have been dead
so if it were for me if we weren't
together he'd be dead already and I'd
probably be sitting in the house smoking
my life away still
by myself
what would you guys say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
always been nice to to always just be a
good person and be who you are never
change who you are for anything you know
and yourself and cherish people around
you for who they are and um always look
out for the next person whether they're
looking out for you or not because you
know
it'll make you feel better yeah and life
won't give it back to you what you put
out for the most part
that's not to say that bad bad things
don't happen to good people and good
things don't happen to bad people but
it's better to be a good person and you
never know you could just make a big
impact on somebody who's totally [__]
evil
yeah
like I changed the gang member to not be
a part of a gang and like this game is
known for killing people who want to
drop out you know and I made the impact
to make him move and not be a part of it
no more and they respected it
so
yeah everything on that you know
all right randina Alex thank you so much
for sharing your stories
I wish you guys lots of luck out here
thank you very much